[Musique]
serge oui alors cette chanson mais si
mon vieux on enregistre demain reste war
je compte sur toi et un effort pour une
fois pas d'obligation est en effet une
profession libérale lega va au bureau à
8 heures et les livres
oui je suis les plus plats journée ce
qui ne sut jamais d'une à deux heures du
matin ou à quatre heures par les déserts
travers le monde
ce sera fait cette machine
essayer de passer
en proportion de ce métier vous écrivez
je pianote sur un char je vais en
yougoslavie on le ressort à l'image
le sang et or ces tirs et que l'effet
que ces fonds
chavanel
je prêche sur le france france que le
premier à traverser durant ces grecs
moi je suis devant mon piano ça me
revient comme ça quand vous monde
alors ce côté-là ses côtés des
martiennes et a tendance à bouffer
l'être humain si ce vide à la tête sur
les épaules et vous verrez forte
je n'ai même pas résisté j'ai fait de la
peinture 1,15 à 15 ans l'âge et mesurer
ce que ces cours de génie est ce que
c'est que moi qui vois que j'ai discuté
collection en avant
[Musique]
doc de public le pas nécessaire
impossible métier intéressant et j'ai
réussi à élever ses enfants s'est dit
luan dans les boîtes de nuit ou de
produits qui m'a appris le piano et
carmaux choix sans clavier parce qu'ils
violaient et bien c'est grâce à lui de
faire ce que j'ai bâti des jeunes et des
associations comme et sur 40 10 des cas
cette cache pas juste de 1000 hectares
pour vous apporter quelque chose
c'est moi japonais est-ce que ça va je
me souviens bien watashi wa you minnelli
au chan sunninghill ni opening ending
mis au ban
non non non la différence était bien ces
vaccins que jamais
oui je vais vous recherchez qu'est ce
que ça représente pour vous cette petite
baisse de 45 millions $ rien quoi ce duo
fâché satisfaction aussi c'est marrant
j'ai moins inquiété que nous point nommé
ticket reichmann intellectuelle
sophistiqué incompris de mes
compatriotes
voilà moi j'aimais le jazz du modern art
6 modern jazz moderne 21 personnes
haskell ou alors une minorité parce
qu'il est il a touché coach et a redit
si je
des preuves et dégueulasse tu vas y que
je n'ose pas aimé si au niveau cinéma il
aime ça au cinéma il aime les films
violents terrible méchant mais dans la
chanson c'est faux chez les gens je vais
aimer ce qu'ils veulent non un troll est
structurée mais dans les chansons se
passer à la chanson il faut que public
se reconnaissent dans les gares pour moi
c'est plus élaboré j'y pense c'est
souvent j'avais tout seul il faut
simplement rostro pendant un dîner
support est à l'esprit disque même quand
il prit disqualifie d'ascenseur en panne
et du pêcheur et modernise et du modern
jazz hip étant tombée tandis hariri
alors
j'ai téléphoné en 2010 je les ai vus new
york d'où tu sors l'amour je fais tout
ce qui est contre
je vais couper la queue de son chien
puis la vie mais il avait bon car il
voulait pas lui faire de mal alors tu es
matin vous perdiez pas de tenue scénique
non j'ai une tenue cynique du cimic que
je trouve scénique parce qu'elle vienne
la décontraction
mais avant on disait que j'avais obtenu
scénique une tenue cynique
on dit je suis prétentieux savoir
scientifique
j'étais chez des lieux aussi grand qu'il
était en espagne vingtaine d'années je
sais le coup ces cellules et il y avait
un salon tapissé d'astrakan sa main
forte impression
les mannequins de deux demandes que vous
l'avez sur lesquels il y avait dessiné
des fourmis allant de chine autour des
yeux
j'ai gardé on s'épaule surréalisme j'ai
un peu ses goûts du fantastique
du baroque je vois les dragons vous
j'aime l'alliage une question d'argent
en chine que vous avez eu des ordres d
une misère est monstrueuse mais
extrêmement esthétique les enfants gulli
mais les noms les enfants vous c'est un
vieux nîmes il met les plus beaux
enfants de la terre c'est très dur
trois autres
et toujours été ce que j'étais prise de
parts
deux boîtes je serai la nuit
les idées plus claires - théoriquement
du vent est très moderne au xxème siècle
dans la lignée des prêts et dépôts l air
de musiciens de vrai
faire la musique atonale points
et rêveur
les bras les salles en effet j'avoue
j'en ai bavé mon amour avant d'avoir eu
vent de vous mon amour la réussite
qu'est ce que ça représente
on sait simplement
[Musique]
la perte non l'argent et c'est tout le
fric
l'argent frais a des goûts dispendieux
de luxe reste un peu monstrueux l'humour
pour moi qu'il a dit il est dit et pour
certains
les boîtes de pudeur et puis
l'agressivité dans les textes aussi si
vous prenez un appareil photo joue le
contre plaqué sur un an
bleu qu'est-ce que vous avez au
développement
raisonnement torture et gtd beau nuage
moi je peux pas me penser qu'une
projection de du moins sur une sur une
scène du moins tel que je suis pouvait
marcher je me semblait même mais c'était
quand même embêtant pour un gars qui
vous créer quelque chose de se sentir
oui mais quand ça veut rigoler
enfin j'aurais préféré qu'ils
arriveraient un peu moins que ce soit
vraiment moins cher
et ça s'est fait comme ailleurs ça roule
[Musique]